foreign
[Music]
oh my gosh can you guys all agree that
Vampire Academy fans are so freaking
talented
[Applause]
okay so for this next segment we asked
peacock's Instagram fans to slide into
our DMS to ask the questions they're
dying to know about the show everyone
will answer a damned fan question that
was sent to us via Instagram for those
of you watching keep a weather eye out
you might see yours first up is Mia
at the headquarters asks what's the
funniest story that happened on set
okay
um funny stories there's hundreds of
funny stories I think I spent the whole
time laughing um one would be we were
doing a scene myself Janetta and Jay and
we grew well people called us the
Tresemme no The Three Amigos yeah and
then as we were about to they're like
rolling they're about to call Action and
Jay just goes translations which means
three mils I think it's five so me and
Jeanette just stopped dying and then
obviously having to film a scene
um every time they're about to say
action hearing Tres Leches it was the
only phrase I knew in Spanish with three
in it so
right that made the cut of the show wait
I'm sorry it wasn't the name of the
hotel yeah
yes yes exactly oh you're right yeah
I could have gone for that one yeah
yes exactly yeah he was going for three
kids
Joy
that's a very good question
um this has to just be one
um I would say all of them were amazing
to film but my favorites would be
probably nine and ten
oh yeah very juicy yeah
and then uh for re at silda understood
Jay ask
s how similar are you to your character
I don't know if I like that reaction
I'm quite quite similar I think the the
whole um
sarcasm and being a bit more brutally
honest than everybody would care for me
to be
um it's something I have a habit of
doing in the best way right
um but no I think yeah and she's and
she's secretly really sensitive our next
question is for Joe NADA and it's from
Advent Academy Army and they ask if you
could be a vampire from Vampire Academy
which would you be oh it's a really hard
question
[Laughter]
I'd be Sonia carp
we can wear some pretty dresses
she's got some gorgeous dresses yeah the
next question is for Jay August this is
from Vampire Academy bound they ask
what's an emoji that that describes your
character
nobody get naughty Jay what right
one one would be a spoiler so I can't
say that so can I choose three yeah okay
so so it would be uh the sunshine Emoji
the wide-eyed Emoji guy and then another
Sunshine Emoji because when Victor
lowers his eyes they turn golden
what's your favorite BTS moment
not the band
[Laughter]
um
I think we all went to Barcelona on the
same weekend and I think we all met up
and we had just the best time and we
were filming a bunch and it was just
very hectic and working and working and
working and we saw Barcelona all
together and it was really special
so the next question is for Julie at
pink Under score room underscore reads
asks what do you hope new and old fans
take away from the show
oh gosh I mean I hope new fans are like
this is awesome
but I think old fans of the books will I
hope really um
might take a minute but hopefully you'll
appreciate the way that Marguerite and I
took sort of everything that we loved
about the entirety of the book series
and and worked it in to our take in our
adaptation of the television series
we're huge fans of the material and so
we wanted to make sure all those great
moments found their way into the
episodes eventually so sometimes it's
not like where you think it's going to
be but it's probably in there if it's a
moment that you loved so generally
speaking I hope everybody loves
everything
and Julia Marguerite I know you guys
have known each other for like 20 plus
years how has that like impacted your
collaboration the trust the like your
creative process all of that
well I mean I'm her biggest fan and have
been you know for a long time like
pre-share of Forbes days but dating all
the way back to a show we did together
called Kyle XY I think she's one of the
most magnificently talented people on
this planet uh and certainly certainly
in everything that she does but also uh
on the page as a writer so if Margarita
says she likes something I'm like okay
but my favorite thing besides every
ditto 100 back to you I mean it's Julie
Fleck we all know how brilliant she is
but one of my favorite things with you
is when we get on a roll well we're
breaking a story and we're like I don't
know what's the thing the thing we both
will suddenly say the same Rando word
out of the blue that nobody will have
thought of it we're like
we got oh my God so there's these
moments where we're literally like our
brains are starting to meld when they
get there and they get there and it
makes me laugh so hard because there's
just this weak come at it from this
different process and we land in the
same place and it's so thrilling and so
enjoyable but also if we were shooting
in Europe in Spain and we shared a flat
we were roommate we were roommates and
we um we wrap it like four in the
morning and we'd come home and we'd
drink beer and eat Laughing Cow Cheese
and do our book and do all of our little
homework at the end of the day can you
see somebody breaks an ankle or
something you have to shift some scenes
around and you know that's what you do I
appreciate that
I'm like week one somebody breaks
[Music]
but it was fun it was really really fun
[Laughter]
I love you Marguerite and it's from
lauric book dragon and they ask which
episode you can't wait for people to see
how hard you guys it's really really
hard this is hard because
one of the things I'm the most proud of
is that every episode that you watch the
next episode feels like it gets deeper
and better and more exciting because we
know the characters more and we're more
excited by the adventure so I feel like
if if I said it was two it would be
three and if I said it was three before
and all the way through so I just feel
like I'm this is a Cheesy answer but I'm
kind of excited for them to see the
entirety of the series I'm so excited
the cast has finally seen most of it and
I'm like now you know what you're in
right and they're like oh my God yeah so
I think that's my answer I just want
people to like love the whole thing
yeah enjoy it as a whole and for CeCe at
Vampire Academy bound ask how many tick
tocks or reels are in the drafts right
now from Spain oh my God
okay no no actually let me think about
this
okay I'm gonna say like eight
um however I have a list of about a
hundred ideas that I had thought of and
that I've been slowly executing so you
will see some crazy some crazy stuff I
just I literally have this image of you
I thought based on your your Instagram
like I'm like CC just sits at home at
night and like the middle of the night
she can't sleep she's up and she's just
like working the gram working the gram
yeah you're good at it you're right
you're right I love that stuff and like
it's a really good way to connect with
the fans as well like yeah all the fan
art that we see around us they they've
already sent us and they've tagged us
and we get to see it and talk to them so
it's really really cool I love Instagram
social media is an amazing tool our next
question is for Andre at celo hinojosa
asks what did they take from the set
what did I take from the set
valuable experience world of experience
yourself what is this assumption that
I'd be the one today
[Music]
um
it's okay listen
um we all got our chair backs which I
think was really nice we got to take and
obviously I took away all the great
memories and friendships
all right but what I would like to take
from the set there you go that's good
don't keep this unlock by the way uh
maybe because Chris Christian's lighter
I think yeah so that was missing we know
where it is
playing some props but we're not allowed
to talk about it yet because it's
supposed to think I'm sure we will hear
more about the props stolen from set
after the show
Julie's gonna get on all you yeah
um but this next question is for Kieran
at VA cash Stan account asks what has
been your favorite part about joining
the fandom and having a strong fan base
oh well
um firstly the amazing reception
um which has been amazing but also the
um the passion for something that's so
like shared and loved by these people
and we got to win we're part of that
process now and hopefully there'll be a
bond that's even stronger when the show
comes out and we can talk about it a
little bit more
um but yeah I'm just hoping that they
can be as excited as we are when we made
it yeah
just quite it's feel I feel um very
welcome and there's a bit of a relative
Outsider I kind of like the idea of
having a little family with these guys
and hopefully the fans
we love you our next question is for
Daniella at donkey or women ask what was
your favorite costume on the show oh see
you had some good costumes yeah Sonia
Grande did an amazing job and she really
I mean all the outfits that she picked
for Alyssa were incredible
um but there was this one like Valentino
dress like jacket sweater thing that was
so cute and she had these little white
heels and I felt like Jackie
and then
um in like nine and or ten I think it's
ten I wear this beautiful gown and I
have these like sleeves these white like
princesses and a big hoop skirt and uh
Tiara so that one was also like